herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
vor genau einer stunde kamen die
eilmeldung der europaweite digitale
impfpass er kann kommen
die eu-länder und das eu parlament haben
sich geeinigt auf ein cockpit 19
zertifikat also eine verständigung
darauf wie er aussehen soll der digitale
impfpass was er können soll wasser
können muss und vor allen dingen was er
für uns bringt das lange
pfingstwochenende steht an wer da noch
nicht verreisen kann der freut sich
natürlich auf den sommer und möchte dann
wissen was möglich ist wenn er denn
durch europa reisen will
mehr als 31 millionen deutsche das ist
der stand heute sind zum ersten mal
geimpft und schon zehn millionen sind
durchgängig also zum zweiten mal ja und
ein digitaler impfpass der sollte und
soll am besten fälschungssicherer als
das gelbe im heftchen nun grenzen öffnen
freiheiten zurückbringen soll das reisen
durch europa möglich machen wir reden
gleich über die einigung die details
aber auch die probleme den streit den es
gegeben hat und auch über die risiken
unter anderem mit linus neumann vom
chaos computer club in berlin
wir reden dann auch mit peter liese cdu
abgeordneter im europaparlament und der
gesundheitspolitische sprecher der
größten fraktion der svp im europäischen
parlament zunächst aber schalten wir
nach brüssel zu unserem korrespondenten
gunnar krüger der seit wochen und
monaten die langwierigen unendlichen
verhandlungen in brüssel verfolgt hat
deshalb die frage an dich tun kann man
denn sagen das ist heute ein durchbruch
kann man feiern bringt das uns bürgern
jetzt etwas ist das ein guter tag oder
kassen mit wochen und monaten hast du
ein ganz bisschen übertrieben aber
tatsächlich ist die einigung
da und die einigung ist tatsächlich eine
stunde alt und es ist ein typischer
brüsseler kompromiss rat kommission und
die
das parlament also die drei
institutionen der eu die mussten sich
hier auf eine position einigen und sie
hatten sich an zwei punkten ganz
fürchterlich verhakt denn zum einen
hatte das parlament gefordert dass
pcr-test umsonst sein sollen oder
umsonst bleiben sollen und gerade eben
auch für die die noch kein impfangebot
bekommen haben
die mitgliedsstaaten haben gesagt das
machen wir nicht mit wir müssen das
bezahlen wir müssten das auf dauer auch
bezahlen zum beispiel auch für die die
sich vielleicht auch auf dauer nicht
impfen lassen möchten
die mitgliedsstaaten haben also nein
gesagt wer zahlt der bestellt sozusagen
nach dem motto und das ganze hat man
jetzt nur heilen können mit geld aus den
kassen der eu kommission 100 millionen
euro als ein notfonds sozusagen für
tests für menschen die einen schwachsinn
für menschen die viel reisen müssen also
in diesem punkt hat man sich mit geld
einigen können und dann gab es einen
zweiten punkt an dem man sich stark
verhakt hatte das war die frage ob es
trotz dieses impfausweise ist auch
weiterhin für die mitgliedstaaten die
möglichkeit geben sollte
quarantäne zu verhängen oder eben auch
eine testpflicht zu verhängen die
parlamentarier im europaparlament die
haben gesagt ja wozu machen wir das
ganze denn überhaupt wir wollen ja
gerade wie der reisefreiheit durchsetzen
und wir wollen das so zu sagen so ein
grüner haken auf der auf der app die es
dann ergeben sollte also dieses digitale
grüne zertifikate soll man ja auf dem
handy mit sich tragen können und wir
wollen dass dieser grüne haken eben
echte reisefreiheit so wie früher
bedeutete und die mitgliedstaaten haben
allerdings gesagt wir wollen weiter
solche instrumente wie quarantäne oder
testpflicht haben und sie verweisen auf
großbritannien das ist jetzt zwar nicht
mehr mitglied aber da kann man gut sehen
wie schnell sich hotspots bilden können
durch neue varianten und die
mitgliedstaaten haben gesagt das wollen
wir weiter machen das wollen wir weiter
haben so ein instrument also wenn sich
die pandemische lage ändern kann dann so
heißt es in dem kompromiss dann kann man
auf basis von wissenschaftlichen fakten
trotz dieses impfpass ist also weiter
garantien und test nicht verhängen
das ist der kompromiss das ist ein
typischer
whistler kompromiss den man hier
gefunden hat man könnte vielleicht
abschließend sagen dass die
mitgliedstaaten sich in diesem punkt
nicht ganz durchgesetzt haben dass also
das parlament hier einen echten kleinen
erfolg feiern konnte und wenn man noch
bedenkt dass das parlament für also eine
einigung von dem rat also die
mitgliedstaaten und von der kommission
eigentlich gar nicht dringend gebraucht
wird dann ist das schon ein echter
etappensieg für das parlament aber im
ganzen haben sich eben die
mitgliedstaaten schon durchgesetzt sie
haben sich übrigens auch durchgesetzt
mit ihrer forderung nach einer
sechswöchigen übergangsfrist das wird
zum beispiel starten wie in deutschland
die in digital noch ein bisschen
hausaufgaben zu erledigen haben sagen
wir mal zeit geben sich noch auf diesen
impfpass vorzubereiten als man hätte in
dieser zeit zum beispiel in deutschland
noch zeit seinen gelben impfpass in die
apotheke zu tragen wo das eingetragen
wird in die app also diese
übergangsfrist wird kommen und dann
deine frage am ende
schlussendlich zu beantworten wird dass
uns das reisen im sommer in der großen
reisewelle erleichtern
ja das ist die große frage denn
tatsächlich könnte es eben sein das wäre
mein ende juni und noch sechs wochen
drauf rechnet das dann vielleicht
zumindest in deutschland dieser impfpass
dieser digitale etwas noch nicht kommt
wäre der in anderen ländern schon
eingeführt ist ja erst einmal vielen
dank für diese ganz ganz ganz ganz
frische informationen aus brüssel und
vor allen dingen deine einschätzung wir
reden gleich auch noch mal weiter
zunächst aber einfach noch mal der
kleine blick zurück was war die idee
eines digitalen eu impfpass es war so
etwas war sozusagen die aufgabenstellung
die das hoffen wir doch alle man in
brüssel heute einigermaßen gut gelöst
hat die antwort kurz und kompakt
er soll das reisen innerhalb der eu
wieder einfacher machen der europaweite
einheitliche immunität nachweis die idee
vollständig geimpfte negativ getestete
oder genesene erhalten ein einmaliges
zertifikat klassisch in papierform oder
digital
darauf ein qr-code der alle wichtigen
informationen enthält
dieser kann dann an grenzen oder
flughäfen vorgezeigt und kontrolliert
werden
zuständig für die ausstellung der
zertifikate sind die mitgliedsländer
sobald der digitale impfnachweis in
deutschland startet brauchen die nutzer
eine etwa die koffer sap oder
altbekannte corona warb damit die
europaweit überprüfung funktioniert will
die eu die benötigten server
infrastruktur bereitstellen
sprich eine schnittstelle die nationale
apps miteinander verbindet und anerkennt
das problem
deutschland hinkt in sachen digitaler
impfnachweis hinterher statt daten setzt
man hier noch auf den aufkleber und das
alt bekannte gelbe heft
hinzu kommt die drängende frage wer
übernimmt überhaupt die erfassung der
bisherigen corona impfungen mittlerweile
bräuchten hierzulande mehr als 10,4
millionen vollständig geimpft
nachträgliche qr codes diese frage
werden wir natürlich aus sprechen unter
anderem über diese frage mit peter liese
cdu abgeordneter im europaparlament und
der gesundheitspolitische sprecher der
größten fraktion der svp
schön dass sie mit dabei sind und weil
nun alles ganz frische neues ganz frisch
an sie eben die frage was sind denn die
entscheidenden punkte auf die man sich
geeinigt hat und jetzt kommen ja ganz
entscheidend ist und dafür haben wir als
europäisches parlament vor allem meinen
fraktionen und sehr eingesetzt
diese einigung soll nicht nur etwas
technisches bedeuten dass man eben ein
zertifikat hat sondern sie soll auch die
rechte für diejenigen geimpft getestet
oder genesen sind tatsächlich wieder
bringen
es gibt ausnahmen das kann ich auch als
arzt sehr gut nachvollziehen dass wenn
man eine hohe incidents hat mit einer
gefährlichen variante des virus das man
dann vielleicht noch mal nach testet
aber das muss einen wissenschaftlichen
kriterien gemessen sein das darf nicht
willkürlich sein das ist wirklich ein
ganz ganz großer erfolg für das
europäische parlament
und da haben wir uns in der tat
durchgesetzt bei der frage dass sie
test kostenlos sein sollen da ist es so
muss ich gewisses verständnis äußern für
die position der mitgliedsstaaten wer
die musik bestellt muss sie auch
bezahlen und wenn dann im herbst jeder
die chance hatte sich impfen zu lassen
darf man ja schon diskutieren innerhalb
der mitgliedsstaaten ob die steuerzahler
für die tests weiter aufkommen sollen
deswegen da gibt es unterstützung jetzt
vor allen dingen für die übergangszeit
100 millionen euro von der europäischen
kommission damit einkommensschwache und
menschen die unbedingt reisen müssen
sich die tests auf jeden fall leisten
können
aber danach müssen wir das einfach noch
einmal sorgfältig diskutieren
gehen wir einfach noch mal so die ganz
kleinen doch entscheidenden fragen durch
also dieser digitale impfpass für wen
gilt der für wen soll dieses zertifikat
ausgestellt werden für geimpfte
getestete und genießen
ja also wenn man einen positiven pcr
test hat dann ist es ja klar dass man
die erkrankung hat und nach einer
gewissen zeit hat man die erkrankung
überstanden und dann soll es eben sechs
monate lang so sein dass man dann auch
diese freiheiten genießt weil die
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse schon so
sind dass jemand der die krankheit
gerade hinter sich hat sechs monate ist
ein guter zeitpunkt daneben auch sich
nur sehr sehr schwer wieder anstecken
kann hundertprozentige sicherheit gibt
es in der medizin nicht das gilt auch
für geimpfte und getestete da gibt es
immer eine gewisse unsicherheit aber
eine bekannte virologin hat gesagt auch
wenn es in der medizin nichts gibt was
es nicht gibt wenn es in der hundehütte
welt ist es meist der hund und nicht das
zebra also getestete genesene und
geimpfte sind in der regel nicht
ansteckend also sozusagen erstmal das
naheliegende naheliegend ist ja auch die
frage wenn wir jetzt auf die geimpften
kommen welche impfstoffe denn nun
anerkannt werden da hat es ja auch so
ein bisschen streit und diskussionen
gegeben
es ist klar bei uns wird mit biontech
moderner astrazeneca johnson & johnson
geimpft demnächst kommt ihr weg dazu
aber da gab es ja auch streit soll man
jetzt sagen okay wer mit sputnik wie
geimpft ist oder mit sie nowak der
kriegt dann auch dieses zertifikat was
ist denn da rausgekommen europaweit
anerkannt werden alle impfstoffe die von
der europäischen arzneimittelagentur
nach sorgfältiger prüfung zugelassen
wurden also die vier genannten plus
kovac wahrscheinlich noch vor dem ersten
sieg und die mitgliedstaaten haben aber
individuell die möglichkeit auch wenn
sie impfstoffe in einer nationalen
notfall zulassung zugelassen haben was
bei sputnik und sie nowak bei einigen
mitgliedstaaten der fall ist könnte das
individuell anerkennen
und da habe ich heute richtig aber ganz
konkret die frage jetzt noch mal es geht
ja darum in die europäische union möchte
mal einheitlich auftreten wir wollen ja
keinen flickenteppich haben aber heißt
das jetzt am ende dass die ungarn wenn
die jetzt sputnik wie genommen haben und
ihre bürgerinnen und bürger damit
geimpft haben kann der österreicher an
der grenze denn jetzt sagen nee ihr seid
mit sputnik wie geimpft worden
das passt aber nicht da kannst du mir
noch so schön da einen digitalen eu
impfpass zeigen ungarn
ja das ist so und wer als europäisches
parlament hatten eigentlich auch gesagt
diese impfstoffe die nicht europaweit
zugelassen sind sollen gar nicht
anerkannt werden die mittel staaten
wollten da eine ausnahme so dass sie da
noch mal flexibel handeln können
ich glaube das liegt doch jetzt ganz
stark an den vertretern russlands
der antrag für sputnik hat er längst
gestellt sein können aber die firma
erfahren hat die daten nicht vorgelegt
und ich glaube das ist jetzt noch mal
ein grund warum die russen die firma
erfahren die dieses verfahren in der
hand hat jetzt einfach schnell die daten
vorlegen müssen die zeigen dass es ein
guter impfstoff ist ich schließe das
nicht aus aber das muss ordentlich
geprüft werden also sie meinen das
problem könnte sich eben lösen wenn am
ende die daten da sind die immer auch
sputnik wie zum beispiel anerkennt das
ist ja naheliegend aber jetzt ganz ganz
wichtige frage ist denn dann wirklich
also ich jetzt als deutscher sage ich
mal doppelt gegeben habe jetzt den
digitalen impfpass ist dann wirklich das
reisen frei
klick oder kann am ende dann doch noch
mich die quarantäne erwischen
ich lese jetzt hier der kompromiss sieht
nun vor dass nicht in die hoheit der
mitgliedstaaten eingegriffen wird grüner
krüger hat es ja auch so ein bisschen
angedeutet aber die zusätzlichen
beschränkung wie quarantäne für negativ
getestet und so weiter
das soll dann doch noch möglich sein
können eingeführt werden wenn es die
infektions lage erfordert also ist dann
da doch noch eine hintertür dass wenn
ich von deutschland aus nach xy leise in
der eu das dann doch es auf einmal
heisst quarantäne
ja also wir haben als europäisches
parlament sehr darauf gedrängt und auch
durchgesetzt dass dieses zertifikat mit
rechten verbunden ist wenn man
zusätzliche test oder quarantäne
pflichten auferlegt dann muss das gut
begründet sein
das war es in der vergangenheit nicht
immer ungarn hat beispielsweise zu
beginn der zweiten welle im oktober die
einreise für deutsche und viele andere
europäer auch für finden wo eine sehr
niedrige incident zwar in finnland die
einreise verboten gleichzeitig aber für
tschechien weiter erlaubt obwohl
tschechien der hotspot der zweiten welle
war das war eine rein politische
entscheidung und das ist jetzt
ausgeschlossen
ich sage da gibt es gute gründe wenn
eine sehr hohe incidents ist wenn wir
uns mal frau ein land hat praktisch kein
corona und ein anderes land hat eine
sehr hohe incidents mit einer
gefährlichen mutation dass man dann noch
mal zusätzlich testet das ist aus meiner
sicht akzeptabel aber es darf nicht
willkürlich sein es muss anhand von
wissenschaftlichen kriterien
durchgeführt werden und das heißt wenn
wir in deutschland so weitermachen wie
jetzt dass wir uns an die regeln halten
dass die incidents jeden tag runter geht
und dass wir damit auch die neuen
mutationen gut in den griff bekommen
auch mit dem zusätzlichen im fortschritt
im juni mit noch mal sehr viel mehr
impfstoff kommen als wenn bisher
überhaupt hatten
wenn das so weitergeht werden wir in
deutschland sicherlich die reisefreiheit
genießen weil wir eben nicht in die lage
kommen dass aus wissenschaftlichen
gründen uns jemand die einreise
verweigern könnte jetzt haben wir schon
einige fragen von userinnen und user und
wenn sie auch noch fragen haben
einfach her damit herr liebig schreibt
über youtube was mache ich denn wenn ich
gar kein handy habe ich hatte schon
probleme auf der internet web so hatte
mich anzumelden weil dort ebenfalls ein
handy benötigt wurde nicht wir haben es
eben in dem beitrag gesehen qr-codes
smartphone etc
ja was mache ich wenn ich jetzt gar kein
smartphone habe gibt's das ganze dann in
papierform am ende doch auch noch ja es
gibt es in papierform
man kann diesen qr code auf dem handy
haben und das ist sicherlich für die
meisten das bequemste weil das handy hat
man ja normalerweise immer dabei war wer
das nicht möchte wer kein handy hat oder
einfach diesen qr code nicht auf dem
handy haben möchte kann ein
ausgedrucktes stück papier haben wichtig
ist dieser qr-code denn das bringt die
zusätzliche fälschungssicherheit
ich habe selber als im pfarrzentrum
mitgearbeitet und die gelben ins besser
ausgestellt
natürlich musste eine unterschrift einen
aufkleber mit der chargennummer und ein
stempel drauf aber bei dem qr-code ist
es halt so dass das noch besser
hinterlegt ist und kontrolliert werden
kann dass dieser mensch tatsächlich
geimpfte ist 100 prozent gibt es auch da
nicht aber die sicherheit wird durch
diesen qr-code erhöht und da ist egal ob
man den offenen handy oder offen papiere
jetzt hat mir gleich die nächste frage
die relativ einfach ist nämlich vier
wörter wann kommt der impfpass wir haben
es eben von unserem korrespondenten von
100 bücher ja auch schon gehört
es ist noch so ein bisschen unklar wann
es denn kommt sechs wochen noch einmal
übergangsfrist deutschland gehört gerade
zu denjenigen die so ein bisschen das
digitalisieren verschlafen haben hat
also die konkrete frage ist natürlich
wenn man sagt ich möchte jetzt den ich
ja der user schreibt ich habe ja bin ja
schon geimpft wo kriege ich ihnen her
was mach ich und wann kann man denn nun
wirklich das ding in der hand haben und
mit dem qr code was ich weiß nach
portugal warschau oder kopenhagen reisen
ja ich hätte mir sehr gewünscht dass wir
viel früher dran sind die cdu csu im
europäischen parlament hat schon im
letzten jahr ein solches digitales
zertifikat gefordert die fraktionen dann
im januar sehr massiv es gab ja auch
gerade in deutsch
zb von der bundesjustizministerin vollem
recht widerstand auch im europäischen
parlament
die sprecherin der sozialdemokraten war
sehr zögerlich und dass wir jetzt
einfach ein bisschen spät dran sind aber
am ersten steht das europaweit auch in
der technischen umsetzung und dann kommt
darauf an dass jetzt auch deutschland
schnell bei der technischen umsetzung
macht wenn er es probleme gibt wenn das
nicht am ersten siebten steht kann man
übergangsweise da soll ja nicht die
bürgerinnen bürger darunter leiden dass
in deutschland das nicht so schnell
klappt kann man übergangsweise den
gelben und impfausweis weiter benutzen
aber ich appelliere sehr und alle
verantwortlichen in deutschland dass das
dann auch zum ersten siebten klappt und
wer jetzt schon geimpft ist oder in der
übergangsphase geimpft wird kann sich
das umschreiben lassen weil die ärzte
mit dem impfen selber sehr viel zu tun
haben ist der plan dass auch die
apotheken mit einbezogen werden und dass
man da den impfausweis und das
zertifikat dass man vom im zentrum
erhalten hat in den digitalen ausweis
übertragen kann
da haben sie jetzt genau eine sehr
entscheidende frage angeschnitten wir
haben es eben im beitrag ja auch schon
noch mal gesagt das ist eine ganz ganz
große frage vor allem in deutschland
wenn rund zehn millionen menschen schon
zwei impfungen haben also sozusagen
dieses jahr haben können und gerne
hätten
wer füttert ihn denn denn bisher haben
wir das gelbe im heftchen alles auf
papier und es ist so während in schweden
alles digital ist muss ja alles hier bei
uns noch um getragen werden
und da haben die hausärzte ja schon
gesagt das lehnen wir vehement ab heute
als gerade der
vorsitzende des deutschen
hausärzteverbands weigelt nochmal gesagt
jeglicher zusätzlicher aufwand ist
definitiv zu viel für uns man kann den
praxen nicht zumuten dass wir das eben
auch noch machen also diese
nachträgliche digitale erfassung der
impfungen wir sind hausärzte und nicht
das passamt und das hier hat der
vorsitzende des hausärzteverbandes
hessen andreas beck zu uns gesagt
zum einen die technische voraussetzungen
die wir nicht kennen
das heißt wie das letztlich umgesetzt
werden soll ist uns bisher nicht bekannt
so zweiten die zu erwartende riesen
große menge an patienten die eure
zukomme der mensch dazu kommen mit dem
wunsch dass umgesetzt zu bekommen und
zum dritten die wahrscheinlich
unterschiedlicher herkunft der daten das
heißt teil alles was wir gemacht haben
ist eher unproblematisch aber was von
außen kommt über dritte über impfzentren
oder über gesundheitsämter das wird für
uns in diesem thema werden und das alles
zu dem normalen tagesgeschäft und der
institution die wir gerade haben
das wird sehr sportlich werden ja also
die hausärzte heben da die hände und
sagen das können wir gar nicht leisten
aber sie haben jetzt angeschnitten das
war ja auch mal eine diskussion naja
dann machen dass die apotheke aber wie
stelle ich mir das vor ich gehe es in
die apotheke bei mir um die ecke und
dann muss der apotheker das auf einmal
digitalisieren
ja also zunächst mal habe ich großes
verständnis dafür dass die hausärzte das
jetzt nicht zusätzlich machen können ich
stehe in kontakt mit vielen praxen und
insbesondere die medizinischen
fachangestellten sind schon sehr sehr
belastet weil natürlich jeder sofort die
impfung haben will und das geht jetzt
gerade im mai eben noch nicht weil der
impfstoff noch knapp ist aber die
information ich habe von den herstellern
von der bundesregierung und auch von der
landesregierung ist dass es im juni noch
mal sehr viel mehr wird dann werden wir
auch jetzt aber wirklich gebraucht wie
die betriebsärzte auch um schnell viele
menschen zu impfen und das umschreiben
der zertifikate von schon geimpften das
muss anders organisiert werden bei den
impfzentren
kann es so laufen dass die dort geimpft
wurden einen qr code zugeschickt
bekommen der aber passgenau für die
personen vorgesehen ist also nicht dass
jeder dann mit dem qr code irgendwo
hingehen kann bei denen die in
hausarztpraxen geimpft wurden geht es
dann über die apotheken die sind ja auch
ja qualifiziert in der apotheke gibt es
ja qualitätsanforderungen für vieles und
deswegen ist es quasi auch eine stelle
mit autorität
man muss zugeben dass da natürlich noch
mal eine schwachstelle ist dass man im
schlimmsten fall einen gefälschten
impfausweis nehmen kann und damit in die
apotheke gehen kann aber erst ist ist
klar fälschung von ausweisen ist jetzt
eine straftat
da sollte sich also jeder davor hüten
und der apotheker kennt ja auch in der
regel sein klientel und kann dann im
zweifel auch noch mal nachfragen wenn
ihnen etwas komisch erscheint das ist
keine personalie jetzt sagen wir reden
darüber so als ob die sachen schon
geregelt sind
es gibt viele user die jetzt hier
schreiben erika l per mail wie und wo
kann man den vorliegenden impfnachweis
alter impfpass oder den alten ebenfalls
eben in diesen neuen infos tauschen
wo kann ich denn da hingehen etc ich
möchte das gerne also gibt es viele
fragen drängende fragen für das hört
sich jetzt so ein ich frage sie jetzt
einfach mal wissen die apotheker schon
von ihrem glück dass sie zum passamt
werden was die hause erziehen nicht sein
wollen also darüber wird verhandelt und
wie so oft geht es natürlich ums geld
die apotheker möchten das nicht umsonst
machen also muss die bundesregierung
dafür eben auch finanzielle mittel zur
verfügung stellen und ich sage nochmal
wir werden viel besser dran wenn wir uns
früher um diese tag um diese frage
gekümmert hätten aber denken wir alle
mal fünf monate zurück
im januar gab es in der öffentlichkeit
sehr sehr wenig verständnis dafür dass
man menschen die geimpft sind rechte
zurück geben sollte weil die meisten
menschen einfach gar nicht gesehen haben
dass sie die chance haben auch eine
impfung
ich war von anfang an dafür dass wir
eine solche lösung
machen wir haben das wie gesagt schon
letztes jahr gefordert aber es gab in
deutschland überwiegend auch in der
bundespolitik in den medien in der
bevölkerung eine große skepsis gegenüber
solchen instrumenten und deswegen haben
wir jetzt leider diese probleme aber ich
bin sicher wir werden diese probleme in
deutschland lösen können ich kann nur
appellieren dass alle da wo sie
verantwortlich sind dass jetzt möglichst
schnell anpacken damit geben sich aber
schon zu dass also deutschland komplett
verschlafen hat wie gesagt den schweden
wird jede spritze digitalisiert von
anfang an jede spritze jeder
impfspritzen gegeben wird ist
automatisch digital festgehalten
und ich glaube vor dem 28 dezember wo
mit großem brimborium die erste spritze
in deutschland gesetzt worden ist glaube
ich schon relativ klar gewesen dass das
gelbe im heftchen nun nicht der
zukünftige standard sein kann sondern
dass man vielleicht dann doch mal
digital festhalten sollte wer geimpft
ist also da muss man doch sagen würden
sie dann eben auch sagen hat deutschland
ist komplett verschlafen
also digitalisierung im gesundheitswesen
sind deutschland ein problem wer als
europäisches parlament haben schon vor
vielen jahren verlangt im rahmen einer
europäischen gesetzgebung über
patientenrechte dass man eben zum
beispiel ein digitales rezept bekommt
das war immer ein schwieriges thema zur
zur damaligen zeit sagte der fdp
gesundheitsminister daniel bahr dass das
eben mit der deutschen erster schafft
nicht zu machen ist
ich sehe in der ersten schafft jetzt
sehr viel mehr unterstützung für
digitalisierung aber deutschland hinkt
in der tat zurück und da müssen wir
aufholen das ist ja sicher auch eine der
lehren aus der korona pandemie dass wir
bei der digitalisierung einfach besser
und schneller werden müssen
vielen vielen dank für diese
einschätzung auch und für diese ganz
ganz ganz frischen erklärungen und auch
die antworten recht herzlichen dank und
günter krüger und sie haben ja gesagt
ein paar wochen ja den einen wird es
ärgern wenn man noch warten muss denn
viele fragen sind ja eben wo kann ich
hingehen wann kriege ich den impfpass
also
immer noch geduld was aber das
digitalisieren in deutschland angeht da
sind wir eben auch selber sozusagen
schuld dran trotzdem vielen vielen dank
für die informationen viele grüße nach
brüssel danke für das gespräch und wir
reden jetzt mit linus neumann vom chaos
computer club in berlin über den neuen
digitalen impfpass ja und eben auch was
er alles bringen kann können sie sich
denn jetzt nach dem gespräch irgendwie
vorstellen nehmen wir mal an sie sind
jetzt zweifach geimpft dass sie das
gelbe im heftchen gehen zu ihrem
apotheker gehen und sagen hier macht man
qr code zur aus zunächst einmal ist
festzustellen dass gespräch hat gerade
so geklungen als gäbe es dieses gelbe
heftchen gar nicht wir haben ja längst
ein impfpass der auch international
anerkannt ist
insofern erübrigt sich dieses konzept ja
eigentlich neu ist jetzt eine schnelle
digitale überprüfung und die will man ja
eigentlich nur dann bauen wenn man davon
ausgeht sehr häufig und sehr viel und
sehr schnell
diese im pässe kontrollieren zu wollen
mit anderen worten hier geht es um die
allgegenwärtigkeit einer solchen prüfung
und damit natürlich auch potenziell eine
hohe benachteiligung von ungeimpften und
für viele ist das ja längst noch keine
freiwillige entscheidung sind weit unter
25 20 15 prozent weniger als 15 prozent
der leute bisher doppelt geimpft und ich
sehe hier eigentlich erst mal nur ein
massives benachteiligung instrument und
machen wir das noch gar nicht so viel
sorgen darüber welche probleme dann
natürlich auch mit dem digitalen
einhergehen aber grundsätzlich haben wir
ein gesellschaftliches problem
und solche digitalen interesse sind
nicht teil der lösung sondern teil des
problems
reden wir darüber gleich weiter aber
oftmals ist ja auch der gedanke gewesen
dass der gelbe impfausweis den mann hat
dass der ja nicht fälschungssicher ist
also sagte das ja eben auch da kann auch
ein jemand mit einem gefälschten ausweis
dann zur apotheke gehen und hat ja
gerade einmal der hinweis gegeben das
sollte man nicht tun
aber ist denn der digitale
impfpass dann fälschungssicherer oder
ist der auch tor und tür sozusagen offen
also zu beginn der pandemie haben sie
ärztin gefunden die ihnen irgendwelche
schweren atemwegserkrankungen und
attestiert haben und in sogenannte
masken attest ausgestellt haben die
papier fälschung sind heute schon
allgegenwärtig und sie werden auch in
zukunft unehrliche ärztinnen und
unehrliche apothekerinnen oder wer auch
immer die dinge am ende aus stellt
finden
entscheidend ist nicht die
fälschungssicherheit england ist der
druck oder die motivation so etwas zu
tun und wenn dieser ausweis entscheidend
wird für den zugang zum öffentlichen
leben dann ist das ein hoher druck
gleichzeitig müssen sich das so
vorstellen der muss ja irgendwo auch
kontrolliert werden und im reisebereich
komme ich gleich noch mal zu aber wenn
sie jetzt nicht vorstellen ein solcher
ausweis sollte kontrolliert werden am
eingang ein geschäfts am eingang eines
restaurants sonst stehen leute gegenüber
für 8 euro 50 die stunde
die reißen sich doch da jetzt nicht
irgendwie stress mit ihnen ein für 8
euro 50 die stunde und scheuchen die
kunden weg das heißt da wird dieses
instrument gar nicht so funktionieren
wie man es sich vorstellen eine
technische frei bevor wir uns darüber
weiter unterhalten blitzschnell eine
technische frage die ich nicht
beantworten kann marcel schuster fragt
über youtube genau sie herr neumann
was passiert denn eigentlich bei einem
gerätewechsel kann man den digitalen
impfpass selbst auf ein neues handy
übertragen
das ist er ja noch nicht raus also auch
ganz vorsichtig die frage an sie aber
vielleicht haben sie eine vermutung
das ist ein relativ simples digitales
signiertes dokument in dem eigentlich
nur drinsteht vorname.nachname
geburtsdatum wurde geimpft oder getestet
oder ist genesen und das ist ein relativ
einfaches datenformat und das ist dann
signiert von einer zentralen instanz
davon also wir haben eine signatur kette
zu einer zentralen instanz aber sagen
sie können offline und das ist schon mal
einer der wenigen vorteile dieses
verfahrens sie können
flein prüfen ob dieses zertifikat echt
ist und dafür brauchen sie nur den
qr-code den können sie sich ausdrucken
wurde ja gerade auch schon gesagt wir
können sie sich tätowieren lassen wenn
sie da total darauf stehen denen können
sie aber auch in der app unterbringen
das ist relativ unkritisch
entscheidend ist das dokument selber hat
ja gar keine gültigkeit
ohne ein ausweisdokument was auch sagt
sie sind diese person also den qr code
können sie sich wie gesagt auch fünfmal
kopieren oder so der hat quasi keine
sehr ist einfach kopierbar und die
fälschungssicherheit ist in der aussage
des koreakriegs also wenn sie den
qr-code wenn sie sich selber einen
erstellen wollen und steht was weiß ich
linus neumann wurde dienst der wird dann
als nicht signiert und deshalb auch
nicht echt und nicht vertrauenswürdig
anerkannt im falle eines anerkannten
muss aber immer noch sichergestellt
werden dass die sie sind oder ich ich
das ist das was ich in den letzten tagen
als er darüber gesprochen worden ist
schon gehört habe und ich komme nämlich
darauf was ihr eben schon sagt das
kontrollieren also was ist denn wenn ich
das smartphone von meinem bruder nehmen
und oder von ihnen sie sind sage ich mal
negativ getestet oder sie sind schon
zwei vergeben ich nehme einfach ihre
smartphone mit dem qr code und gehe
jetzt in dem restaurant gestern im radio
sagte eine wirtin ja sie kommen da jetzt
nicht im leben da drauf hier noch eine
ausweiskontrolle zu machen den
personalausweis zu verlangen ich gucke
mir das ding an und dann setze ich den
mann an den tisch da sind wir eben beim
problem kontrollen ja und ich bin mir
gar nicht so sicher ob das ein problem
ist also ich gehe wie gesagt nicht davon
dass die wirtin wirklich ein großes
interesse hat kundinnen weg zu scheuchen
und man darf sich auch wirklich nicht
vergessen vor augen zu führen was das
für den großen teil dieser gesellschaft
bedeuten würde die keine angebote haben
und da werden ja auch verschiedene
phasen unterschieden im moment ist es
einfach nur ein instrument der
gesellschaftlichen spaltung ich nenne
das privilegierung von wenigen ich weiß
diese wenigen menschen bekommen ihre
grundrechte zurück aber grundrechte die
dem größeren teil der gesellschaft in
keiner form verfügung stehen sind in
privilegien ja es wird aber später eine
zeit gegeben in der dieses
die möglichkeiten der impfung potenziell
allen zur verfügung gestanden hat und
dann werden wir eine gesellschaft haben
in der 60 70 vielleicht geimpft haben in
gegeben sind dann haben wir auch eine
situation in der wir potenziell diese
kontrollen gar nicht mehr brauchen weil
wir hoffentlich in der lage sind uns die
paar ins gegnerinnen noch leisten zu
können in der zwischenzeit ist bei einer
harten kontrolle dieser bescheinigung
ich denke tatsächlich nichts geringeres
als die zivilisation wirklich gefährdet
insofern könne eigentlich froh sein dass
die dinger im alltag eigentlich
unbrauchbar sein werden und das ist
vermutlich so leid es mir tut gut ist
dass diese das dass diese kontrollen im
zweifelsfall einfach nicht ernsthaft
durchgeführt werden weil das
diskriminierungs potenzial sich hier
enorm das ist ein klarer aspekt in
klarem punkt den sie gemacht haben
es ist so dass aber eben viele user
bleibt doch die frage um was den
datenschutz angeht der eu impfpass
schreibt
pohl haben wir da bringt vor allem
datenschutz probleme und das grundrecht
ist nicht verhandelbar a wahrscheinlich
rechtsanwalt über youtube der punkt ist
ja auch der viele fragen sich was ist
denn mit dem daten tracking et cetera
impfausweis sie haben es gesagt steht
jetzt nicht so viel aber immerhin doch
mal der name das geburtsdatum etc wenn
mich jetzt jemand kontrolliert der darf
ja eigentlich die daten nicht speichern
oder ist dann da doch wieder touren tür
offen wie sehen sie das denn das treibt
viele um ja und das ist auch genau 1 ein
sehr spannender muss zunächst fangen mit
den guten sachen es ist tatsächlich so
dass hier einige ganz gute mechanismen
eingebaut wurden oder gesetzlich wer in
dieser verordnung vorgesehen werden die
den absoluten datenschutz alb vom in
erster instanz verhindern wir in
deutschland auch so völlig irrsinnigen
systeme gesprochen die im prinzip seine
online abfrage erfordert hätten weil sie
meinten es wäre eine kluge idee das in
irgendwelche fünf blocks zu hinterlegen
da werden sie also online gewesen und
jede nach prüfung ihres engpasses wäre
quasi online durch die betreiber
stattgefunden zentrale datenbank bei der
dann alles unterlegt völlig unsinnige
idee hier wird mit zertifikaten
gearbeitete signaturen sind also offline
fußball das heißt ein location tracking
durch eine zentrale instanz ist erst
einmal nicht möglich dann kommt aber
natürlich das problem dass die menschen
die ihren qr code scannen ja theoretisch
diese daten speichern könnten
das wird ihnen aber untersagt daher
denke ich wie gesagt im normalen leben
supermarkt restaurant und so weit weg
dass kaum eine rolle spielen kommen der
aber zu sehr viel spannenderen
situationen die ich viele viele menschen
sicherlich auch interessant sind flug
internationale zug reisen oder auch der
besuch von konzert- oder stadion ich
denke da wir dann nahm liches ticketing
allgegenwärtig werden und in
diesen bereich entstehen dann quasi
langzeit datenschutzproblematik auf
einer ganz anderen ebene gar nicht
unbedingt dadurch dass wir einen
impfnachweis haben oder einen impfpass
haben sondern dadurch dass der
kontrolliert werden muss
und da sehe ich eher die probleme dass
wir uns eben daran gewöhnen werden dass
wir nicht einfach so zu irgendeiner
veranstaltung gehen können sondern dass
wir potenzielle identitätsnachweise
leisten müssen und das sind natürlich
dann auch zu dingen die mit dieser
sunset kloss die ja durchaus in dem text
vorgesehen ist und potenziellen nicht
wieder zurückgehen und das sind auch
durchaus nennenswerte gesellschaftliche
einschränkungen da fragt man sich
natürlich schon zu welchem preis man
hier ein solches system bauen möchte
linus neumann dann sage ich ganz ganz
herzlichen dank mit herrn leser haben
wir über die details gesprochen die
heute frisch entschieden worden sind sie
haben einfach den horizont auch noch mal
ein bisschen erweitert und einige große
fragezeichen dahinter gesetzt vielen
dank für ihren anstoß für ihren beitrag
vielen dank und liebe grüße nach berlin
vielen dank ja dann sprechen wir einfach
noch mal mit gunnar krüger unserem
korrespondenten in brüssel gunnar du
hast beide gehört leese mit einigen
details noch einmal auch mit dem klaren
ja würde ich mal sagen bekenntnis dass
deutschland da einiges auch verschlafen
hat jetzt würde man aber wahrscheinlich
in brüssel sagen mensch wir haben so
lange gerungen jetzt haben wir doch
endlich den impfpass auf denen ihr alle
gewartet habt und linus neumann hat auch
würde ich mal sagen ordentlich wasser
indem seinen geschüttet wie siehst du
denn die ganze mixtur was siehst du da
in dem glas kann man sagen das ist doch
ein erfolg mit blick nach vorne oder
sind da doch viele schwachstellen und
dinge die noch gar nicht gelöst sind
ich glaube man kann aus sicht der eu
sagen dass man zumindest in einem punkt
mal einen fehler vermieden hat den man
in der vergangenheit ja gemacht hat wenn
wir uns zurück denken an die korona
kontakt verfolgung sap die viele von uns
schon lange nicht mehr aufgemacht haben
oder die eben auch nicht miteinander
sprechen können also
wir hier in belgien haben unsere eigene
kontakt verfolgung sap und die war lange
zeit eben nicht verbunden mit der
deutschen hat man dass es im nachhinein
machen müssen das ganze war also digital
gesprochen ja wirklich ein desaster und
dieses desaster da hat zumindest die eu
diesmal die chance wahrgenommen
vielleicht in vorne vornhinein ein
bisschen mehr vorzuarbeiten also gleich
einen zentralen server anzubieten wo -
man hat das ja eben erklärt eben nur ein
nur ein minimum an daten ausgetauscht
wird wohl nur der schlüssel ausgetauscht
wird also da hat man schon vieles besser
gemacht
was zeigt aber auch noch einmal dass
auch europa hier sozusagen einen
digitalen graben hat
wir haben in den letzten tagen uns
beispiele eben aus schweden angeschaut
und die auch in beiträgen verarbeitet
und man sieht einfach diese länder sind
über jahre hinaus auch gestern dass
dafür ein beispiel sind über jahre
hinaus daran gewöhnt dass medizinische
patientendaten gespeichert werden und
dass die eben auch daten sicher aber
eben gespeichert werden und dass man das
gesundheitssystem digitalisiert und da
sieht man auch wenn in deutschland schon
vieles digitalisiertes es wird dabei an
vielen verschiedenen stellen
digitalisiert und dann den knopf
umzulegen und eben ende juni zu sagen so
wir haben hier etwas hinterlegt das kann
man an jeder beliebigen grenze an
gehwegen beliebigen konzertsaal eintritt
ort abgleichen diesen knopf umlegen das
schafft deutschland eben nicht und so
könnte es sein dass man am ende dieser
ganzen diskussion um den in spa sieht
dass man sich entscheiden muss ob man in
europa in puncto digitalisierung in
puncto gesundheits union
ob man da weiter gehen möchte ob man
mehr europa haben möchte oder ob man die
mitgliedstaaten weiter für sich arbeiten
lernen möchte klar ist aber dass beißt
sich mit dem mit der großen
errungenschaft von europa das ist
schließlich die reisefreiheit und dieser
gelegen die menge lage entscheidet sich
am ende die frage ob das hier in triumph
ist oder nicht
ich glaube das ganze wird am ende nicht
so heiß gekocht wie wir ist jetzt in
erwartung unseres sommers unseres
sommerurlaubs sehen am ende wird
wahrscheinlich schon jeder in st
urlaub fahren können aber ja eine der
hat ja vielleicht ein bisschen bequemer
weil er es auf der app vorzeigen kann
und der andere der muss das mit papier
nachweisen aber an linus neumann hat ja
auch gesagt es liegt im interesse der
veranstalter im interesse der hotels und
gastwirte kunden zu haben und so darf
man darauf hoffen dass eben nicht nur
der digitale ausweis sondern eben auch
papier anerkannt wird jetzt noch mal
ganz ganz kurz qe2 ganz kurze
detailfragen auch von den userinnen und
usern oh läck schäfer zb fragen über
youtube hat der eu impfpass denn auch
eine gewisse kraft außerhalb der eu das
ist schon der nächste schritt jetzt
haben wir heute gerade mal sozusagen
verabschiedet oder sich darauf geeinigt
aber trotzdem die frage an dich wird das
in brüssel auch diskutiert überlegt man
schon mal weiter ob dann der digitale eu
im spaß am ende vielleicht auch hilft um
ich weiß nicht was in die usa zu fliegen
also das ist glaube ich schritt für
schritt ganz eindeutig ist haben heute
die gesundheitsminister sich hier in
brüssel getroffen und die haben sich mal
in umgekehrter richtung gedanken gemacht
wen möchte man in zukunft reinlassen und
da sieht man schon einige versatzstücke
des kompromisses den man heute gesehen
hat in bezug auf drittstaaten also aus
von menschen die aus ländern kommen die
nicht der eu angehören und da hat man
eben auch klar die 3g s gewesen getestet
und geimpft festgehalten und man hat
auch dort festgehalten dass man gerade
nochmal die staaten in denen es hot
spots gibt es in denen es varianten gibt
dass man diese staaten natürlich
weiterhin vom flugverkehr aushalten
aushalten möchte also es gibt umgekehrt
sicherlich den gedanken dass man test
nachweise einfordert von menschen die in
die eu komme und dass diese test
nachweisen dann die gleiche qualität
haben müssen wie zum beispiel der eu
sowie tim passt ja und auch noch ich sag
mal eine berechtigte frage hätte man den
kollegen liese da eben noch fragen
können
selina schreibt über youtube werden die
kreuz impfungen auch überall anerkannt
also wären ja gesagt also die kreuzung
mainzer halt erst die impfung
astrazeneca die zweite impfung bei
montech werden eben darüber
gesprochen welche impfstoffe welche
impfungen werden denn anerkannt
astrazeneca bei montech zu vermuten wäre
ja dann eben auch jemand der mit
astrazeneca und dann bei montech geimpft
worden ist aber ist dass irgendwo
festgehalten worden können wir also
selina beruhigen also dieser kompromiss
ist eine stunde alt oder jetzt gut
anderthalb stunden alte und in den
details habe ich ihn mir noch nicht
durchlesen können aber ich kann ihnen
sagen man hat sich geeinigt und herr
lisa hat das auch schon angesprochen
man hat sich ja geeinigt in dem punkt
dass man all die die impfstoffe die von
der europäischen arzneimittelagentur
zugelassen sind dass man die als
nachweis für info anerkennen möchte und
all die die noch nicht zugelassen sind
das stimmten trifft zb zu für den
russischen impfstoffes brodnik wie oder
auch für den chinesischen sinopec dass
da jeder mitgliedstaat selbst
entscheiden kann ob er die als nachweis
für impfung anerkennen möchte das könnte
zum beispiel dazu führen dass ungarn
wenn sie nach österreich fahren dass die
darauf hoffen müssen dass auch
österreich sie nowak anerkennt also
solche gedanken hat man sich gemacht das
hat man geregelt also in dem punkt
freiwilligkeit was kreuz impfungen
angeht da muss man nochmal ganz tief ins
kleingedruckte gucken so ist es denn die
ganze einigung ist wir haben es gesagt
nun muss man schon sagen anderthalb
stunden sozusagen als wunder insofern
ganz ganz ganz ganz herzlichen dank auch
für deine ganz frischen informationen
und einschätzungen aus brüssel noch mehr
details wird es auch geben aber ich
glaube wir haben eine ganze ganze ganze
menge fragen zu dem neuen digitalen eu
impfpass beantwortet und insofern auch
vielen dank an dich nach brüssel
ja und das war unser zdf heute live
stream zu dem neuen eu im pass können
insofern nur hoffen oder haben zumindest
erfahren dass wir noch ein bisschen
geduld haben müssen dass auch viele
dinge vielleicht noch nicht ausgegoren
sind wer in deutschland digitalisiert
viele interessante antworten haben wir
aber bekommen vielen dank für ihr
interesse
tschüss und auf wiedersehen